so tear started this is a tutorial on
basically approximate baby
to recap nice in theory talk about
variational currents take that from the
basics of linear regression stuff
already seen before probably all that's
agenda is adversary networks and in the
last section we're going to have a quick
overview of some recent work kind of
uniting the two schools of implicit and
explicit genitive models being published
in ITIL
and presented tomorrow so we're beating
them by a day on that research so just a
quick recap
Who am I I'm a CML research launcher
systems we do high throughput latency
trading software for sports betting
markets mercenary interesting problem
areas at the moment we're actually
hiring for a Python developer explicitly
but we happy to meet with people from a
range of skill sets who interested in
maybe finding out more about what we do
I've got three guys as well with me down
the front here so if you're interested
talk more about that come find us
afterwards okay so and as always with
these presentations just to head off any
questions about why pint or attentive
flow opening with that and I've used
both I used to be attentive oh when it
was basically just Canseco and they both
have pros and cons I mean if you write
Python a lot I think part is way more
similar to what you do is very easy to
just switch in and out from numpy and
apply torch pretty quickly downside it's
pretty new it's very very bleeding edge
at the moment basically half the
functionality this talk uses is in
version or point four it was introduced
that landed two days ago so if you
prepared an installed more than two days
ago you have to upgrade so that's
obviously downside it's very Alf at the
moment but doing really great stuff okay
just a point of notation we see some
formal ease and stuff
I think it's generally agreed upon
standard but just to recap small case
non bold means like a one day to make
one dimensional data point bolded mean
multi-dimensional that can include 1d
because that's in initial space as well
and capitalized norm is a matrix and
understand it why is generally target
and that be a weight okay so if you want
to follow along and this is my github
page with all the slides and the
notebooks on it I'm not going to run any
code here today just because these
models take a while and I've already run
them so we can see the output I'm not
sure it's instructive just to watch on a
train decrease so people feel free your
own time to go through them so some
prerequisites I kind of expect you've
seen probability before and basic
Bayesian terminology and some reason
important more knowledge you know what
regression is it's probably gonna be a
heart and a half for you so organs do
today I said recap some some key ideas
kind of try and read a fairly consistent
path through variation Ferentz just
probably the screw natives V agent ganz
I said there's a lot to cover when
you're putting together talk about this
it kind of you have to put a lot of
stuff in there and how people did go in
do a bit more or we have to concentrate
on one thing and basically cover nothing
for so it's probably gonna be stuff that
it's gonna go of your heads but there's
lots of resources the end of it
besides as well so you can come back and
see other people talk about them okay
there's no perspective if you want okay
so motivation this talk is about doing
approximate Bayesian inference so the
standard one that we probably all see
and probably textbooks everywhere is a
coin toss so if I toss a coin in 22
times I get five heads and 15 tails what
does that mean about the distribution of
a coin game talk about a Bayesian
framework I'd be saying I'm looking for
a posterior distribution of the coins
bias so like the probability that it's
heads versus tails and this is a very
obviously very standard problem Bayes
theorem
I'm sure you've also been in probability
whatever most real-world problems are
they followed the same idea but they
nowhere near as simple and so we need to
use approximations because the math
spreads down very very quickly
variational inference is a subset of
approximating inference basically if it
uses optimization to solve the problem
it's generally called operational
parents things like marketing Monte
Carlo also fall into approximation for
the state vocational France okay so what
kind of problems is it useful for
well I mean as it says on the tin
anytime you're looking to apply probe
licit reasoning and so that means if you
want to get on certainty estimates for
things i've classified in your own nets
or you want a to predicted distribution
so season examples in a minute about
what that really means but if we use a
naive approach that we train in our
network I mean just throwing our date
out of sample data we might get put I
get a probability but it's not really
predictive because we don't get a
measure of how much that input point
represents what we trained on and how
similar those things are and also
there's been a lot of success recently
in using these methods to kind of shine
a new light on things that we know that
work in practice
so things I drop out is probably one of
the most famous ones that we can
reinterpret in a variational inference
type framework allows us to apply theory
and probably reasoning to stuff that we
know works incorrectly we discover
empirically okay so the cornerstone and
I hope you've all seen this before okay
and I'm probably anymore this is again a
textual description of Bayes theorem you
have a like normally have parameters
theta and vodka liters of function which
gives you the probability of all of your
outputs or your wives or whatever giving
your Theatre's
your prior is your prior belief so this
can be anything from uniform up to some
very specific belief the posterior is
how I update my distribution of their
parameters now that I've seen data
and so these are the terms in peace
there as I'm sure you've all seen before
okay so we have to cover a little bit of
information theory hopefully you've all
seen this as well
so a divergence measure is how we
essentially measure difference it's
probably the best time to put it between
probability distributions so you can
think of it at a high level is it like a
distance metric but formally to be a
distance metric it has to obey a sieve
variations basically which are given
here and we can react some of these so
like symmetricity and doesn't lessen you
to hold for divergence measure like our
divergence is not symmetric but it still
gives us a quantifiable way to measure
between distributions so the KL
divergence is probably the most popular
one hopefully most of you seen this
before it's not a metric so you can see
it's the expectation of under this
region of Q of the rod ratio of Q and P
so if we if we tap mu Q and P there P
will be the expectation term so there's
obviously not in general the same if you
speak you and key P and this different
the non-terminal H of it induces
different preferences when we learn so
if we have a look at our first
demonstration
okay so at the top here we have we have
the definition to tell their agents
again and this is the reverse form so so
I was talking about for now because we
have ratio in in the vocal term if if we
have depending which formation we have
if the denominator is small that causes
the whole term to blow up but whereas if
in numerator is small then it causes the
whole time to be small so depending
which way you have the ratio induces
different preferences basically so what
I've done here is used sideline as a KL
divergence functions I've just used that
and defined a probability distribution
which is a mixture of two gaussians very
straightforward so if we were to imagine
this was what we're trying to learn and
what we're going to fit I stand at a
normal distribution to this just a
single one
so if we say Q is our approximate
solution we're trying to use and P would
be the mixture so if we're trying to
optimize ki using Q P we can see that
this exhibits what we call the mode
seeking behavior so it sees the best
approximation as matching one of the
modes of the two whereas if we use the
reverse formulation we can see actually
proposed masks are green so and this is
because it's again because of the ratio
it's penalized for hat for there being
mass on the real distribution and no
mass on the proximal distribution so
which formulation you use actually
matters quite a lot because it depends
what you're looking to do because for
example the first exclusion if you're
looking to get really good samples from
across the whole distribution this is
terrible proximation because you didn't
miss that like half the distribution but
if you're kind of looking for more you
know I want to understand the true
variance and things like that this is a
much better thing to do but equally
neither any samples you draw from
this I'm not going to be as
representative of either mode so you
have to think about these things when
you're designing your system okay
so with the preamble done we can move on
to the meat of the talk I guess and so
why the posterior one kind of saw
example oh yeah but the reason we care
about the posterior because it allows us
to compute other good stuff really so if
we want to achieve predictive
distribution Asian sense then this is
the formula so it's essentially the
expectation of the 1/2 sample vodka hood
with the posterior so this is useful for
out-of-sample predictions and on set the
estimates and also maybe you want to do
local Bayesian high parameter section so
you need what's called the model
evidence and we can compute this using
the posterior as well normally we assume
the joint is tractable this is just
multiplying two times together whereas
the evidence is not because all the
posterior is not because he invited on
school terms we see in a minute so
there's two main reasons why we would
use these methods so why then why would
you ever need to approximate well I'm
simply computational requirements
because if we look at pace theorem you
can see that the denominator so Bayes
theorem has an integral in it and this
is fine for some distributions like we
know certain class of distributions like
to normals make a normal and everything
like that and then we tend conjugacy but
for any most real-world examples are
probably not conjugate we just do that
to make it easy and for any two
distributions the chance I if I just
made a joint distribution and try to
integrate it I wouldn't have anything
that was anything we knew as a
distribution so if there's no that easy
analytical answer you basically if you
want to compute this directly you'd have
to do numerical integration and this is
really not scalable because use here
because of dimensionality very very fast
so just an example if these Sigma is the
sigmoid distribution this is there is no
closed form solution to this is is just
a thing but we could compute numerically
but there's no like
I kind of say this is like a BT
distribution this is just what is and
say the only way to get to actually get
an answer to that would be to do
numerically and we've very quickly run
out of computational resources that
would be extortion expensive okay so
just to kind of start on our part we're
going to look at Bayesian linear
regression
so I hope most of you seen this before
so if you have a privacy bution overall
regression weights which is just a
standard normal with a diagonal
covariance matrix and a likelihood which
is a linear function in the mean diagram
covariance and we can derive because we
know that this combination of models is
conjugate we know that posterior is
conjugate simplifies that algebra and I
don't if you've never done this before
it's reasonably worthwhile exercise you
can see something like Bishop for the
steps if you weren't interested but
basically these two terms at the bottom
here are the mean and variance of the
posterior so I've got that just
implemented quickly numpy so we can
okay so this is just a recap again of
the model that we've I just showed on
the slide I've just used the basis
function expansion so these are our X's
here don't apply the Phi's and we know
what our posterior looks like because
we've got the answer already we've done
the maths so it's nice and shape forward
if we generate some data and we
essentially are doing a basis function
which is a third order polynomial down
here so we're fitting a third order
polynomial to this data and to basically
all this code is Jeff implementing the
former that we saw above is not to be
interesting but what we do get is we get
the mean and covariance of the posterior
which we can use numpy der random to
sample from so when we do that and we
put the different regression curves
basically we can see that this is a
reasonably good posterior because when
we sum from the C tribution most of them
fit in the data quite well and what we
see is that the variability start to
increase as we go outside our data so
especially on the left hand side and
this is kind of well-known extrapolating
pastelitos
doesn't eat sensible things sometime so
this is the kind of thing that posterior
asks to see so we can use the predictive
distribution now you can realize on the
same metaphor of conjugacy so this will
give us if we implement this again we
can sample from this distribution which
are predictive which I've done here
again is very straight forward to just
implementing the form where we saw above
and what we get is a part of
competencies for want of a better word
about the location for any X so for any
X this is like a heat map of what the
probability is of Y being at that point
so it's very high around the data which
is good
and Vario when it's not around the data
but the interesting thing we see is if
we zoom in a little bit we can see that
as we move past our data our model gets
less confident to predict any point so
this is actually useful because if we're
doing things where like we're adding an
automatic aircraft and we want to be
really confident that this isn't just
like some overfitting artifact and this
is actually what we've seen before so
having a system where it starts telling
us when all your pain this is what I
think the input is but this is quite far
from anything I've ever seen before and
this is what you get use a Bayesian
approach because even though it will
still predict the mean will still be the
same of this distribution we can see up
here the probability is significant
reduced some stuff gets signal that way
maybe extrapolate and part into my data
okay so that works nice and easily so
it's all analytical all I was doing
there which is implementing some mats in
numpy the reason that works is because
conjugacy so we know a normal that kid
with a normal prior I mean it's still
normal and so we get and everything's
all nice but we may not actually want to
use this in reality I mean normally the
so the right pooping normal means the
errors that we observe are normally
distributed normally we justify this by
saying oh well it's probably got some
little small errors that will add up and
then I can just say so central limit
theorem and not worry about it ever
again depending what you're doing that
may be not true and you might actually
have one single source of error that's
clearly not normally distributed if you
want to do that so you wanted to have
like a road normal distribution of your
error it would work you'd need because
that's not an analytical solution
anymore and for example the normal
tribution you proposed to improvise
symmetricity so that's maybe a strong
assumption for some cases so for example
house prices if you're trying to regress
like true house to learn the true house
price given the price set put on the
market for I'd probably be a safe bet to
assume that that's not symmetrical
distribution people are almost certainly
going to put houses for more expensive
than they're worth a lot more than they
are for less expensive than they're
worth none wants to sell for less than
the house is worth so if you actually
cared about being precise about this
model and the period can you make you
won't be using a normal athlete would
probably be the wrong way to go
I mean also if we have things like our
likelihood is not just a linear function
of our prior and well use more
complicated ways to determine the mean
then also our context he disappears
because it only works because it's a
linear function so normally the first
place we ever fee non-congregate
distributions to do inference and we're
learning about machine learning would be
the class approximation so we're doing
logistic regression and we'll do that in
a Bayesian way it's know me that the
first example is a historical an
approach it's an analytical approach
which we have imprinted here so the
model which is debating the gist
aggression sorry it's basically the same
as we knew aggression except their
livelihood is wrapped with a sigmoid
function so because he's active
classification our outputs are 0 or 1 so
we can interpret this as being like a
probability that Y is cost 1 for example
so this is because of the sigmoids which
is obviously nonlinear function then we
no longer have a quantity this set of
distributions so the posterior here is
not conjugate it's not normal and so we
have to rely on an approximation if you
want to do this so the standard way
would be to use a Taylor series
expansion
I won't depend too much time on this I
promise but basically you do at a series
expansion of any log function in general
is given here and we say ok we're gonna
take the Taylor series expansion around
the map points so essentially the mode
of the posterior because it's the mode
it's a maximum point so it's effectively
0 which allows me to get rid of the
middle term in here so this this guy is
0 so it's all this whole term drops out
here and then we can essentially
recognize all of this as being I don't
know some number because it's a
derivative at a certain point which
we've just called that a and so this
actually starts to go up now like the
blog PDF of a Gaussian and so that's
essentially what they do is they say I'm
gonna take a Taylor series approximation
of this posterior and using the second
derivative at the at the map as the
covariance matrix and in the map point
as the mean so
this is what I've got invented here
hopefully you've all seen British
efficient implements before it's quite
straightforward so I just used their
torch veneer layer here which is just a
weight matrix times your inputs and then
we have a loss function which are binary
cross entropy standard classification
negative world overheads and a prime
mean and variance again which is just
defined as sorry that's a zero one I
hope with the precision multiplier I
don't know if people familiar with the
torch kind of paradigm but generally use
forward to denote the forward parts of
your network for one of Edwards and so
this is just working out all right so
this just works out the linear function
because our last function takes budgets
and then we can apply sigmoid to this
function as well to get the proper
radical output which is given here so
the way we the way we do this
analytically is we do map estimation so
we put a prior on on the loss function
and we solve that and then we just plug
in the this analytical term here as the
covariance so what we've done here so
con- broke out here which is just the
exponent of an or distribution so if we
take a simple classification example
from scikit-learn
so two classes and four books we can
pass this data into our just you
progression and what she's Adam to
optimize it we minimize our loss which
is our likelihood and our prior and we
get a single way to value out and from
there we can just for example visualize
a classification surface that we learned
so it did a very good job mostly the
base point classified it probably could
do a little bit better because easy like
main people
and on the wrong side it's hard to tell
sometimes because sighs but this has
been inputted that prior as well because
it favors much more simple zero mean
weight functions and so if we now
essentially just do that mass again a
bit like we did in numpy and we work out
what our second derivative is it's a
nice analytical form it's not
particularly pretty but we can work out
quite straightforwardly and this is the
mean here so this is just the weight
I've learned from my widget state
regression from the previous step and so
we can do exactly the same thing now I
can I can sample from this distribution
which actually a torch multi variable
Gaussian and we can see that we've
sample all these different operational
services and so again our posteriors
looks reasonably sensible and we can do
the same thing again that is the cast
page in this plan so we can say okay so
imagine I now want to classify the point
100 point 5 so this is obviously I'm
really far away from any of the data
we've seen before and if we did a
Bayesian prediction would get an 80%
probability but because then this is
because we're computing an average over
all these decision surfaces so because
they're different
some of them will it will form one time
some before any other but if we just
used the map point so the most likely
weights that we've determined will see
it'll be super overconfident at Assen
98.7% that this is on crosswalk which is
probably as strong it's probably strong
to be that confident on a point which is
of an order of like 10 times further
away than any point you've ever seen
before so this is why we do things like
Bayesian pretty distribution because we
get slightly more well calibrated and
predict probability outputs as opposed
to just being taking a single output and
deciding that's the one
okay so that was great
but it has some shortcomings we had to
resort to actually doing the maths
Taylor series expansion and it's not
kind of clear how that would work if we
wanted to use some other distribution
there's an approximation if we wanted to
use a mixture of three gaussians
that's gonna get pretty messy the Taylor
series doesn't look about anything like
that so we're not sure how we'd proceed
from there so what we can do is resort
to a much more modern technique which is
a lot more general so this is called the
elbow eye it's also appears in the e/m
algorithm if anyone's ever seen that
before this is the same loss function
for one of a better word in the EM
algorithm derived it tends to be derived
slightly differently in various
literature but it always says purposes
is the same thing so the first point is
that you're looking to minimize so I
want an approximation Q which minimizes
the distance between the distances in
the Carole divergence between my
proximation and my true posterior here
and so we can go through the algebra
it's very straightforward just chopping
up there so taking this is the
definition of the KO divergence where
you can chop that up using Bayes theorem
do some rearranging and it drops out
that we can say that the Doge likelihood
of data Y is greater than this term here
which we call the elbow so the idea
being that because it's Cal divergence
is so we can't compute this because we
don't actually know the posterior but we
know it is positive because it diverges
negative never negatives right so we can
just drop this term turn it into an
inequality and we have a bound and so
this is this helps us because we have an
optimization problem now because instead
of having to compute this term directly
or something we can just maximize this
term and we know that if we maximize it
fully we're going to get inequality and
our proximation will be exact so it
allows us to transfer from probabilistic
methods into optimization and we
more tools to help us out there so we
can do the exactly the same thing we
just did with the Laplace approximation
we can use the elbow instead as a loss
function yep
evidence of lower bound so it's a it's a
strange name but okay so we can use the
elbow as I lost function now so it's the
same model as we saw before and so this
is the form of the loss hunt this is the
form of the elbow sort of chop it up so
we have basically you can consider this
to be like a simplification term or a
regularization term so it penalizes
difference between approximation
approximation in our prior so it acts to
damp down complexity and this is kind of
even called pseudo accurate term so this
is the term that is high when our
reconstruction is good and when our
proximation is good and so we have an
interplay between simple models and
complex models and hopefully this allows
us to find a nice happy medium and so
this is pretty much the same code as
before except now we have also two
parameters which are the mean and a
variance or a variance so whereas before
we essentially trained just our weights
so we can see that as training a
distribution with just the fixed
covariance that we know now to run the
full distribution we have to learn
covariance as well so we have an extra
parameter that we have to optimize for
basically everything else exactly the
same so we've got a forward is basically
the same haven't usually near here just
for simplicity so and in the loss
function now is an implementation of the
of the elbow so the expectation of the
likelihood is just again it's across
entropy and if for the Kerr divergence
term we've got because I'm using the
Gaussian to approximate this
to be consistent and we have an
analytical solution so I've just
implemented that we could also dip Monte
Carlo it doesn't make any difference you
something would be easier for me this
way and so if we see so this is how
different problem but same idea now we
have one side to you now if you want to
learn a covariance matrix it has to be
positive definite if it's a normal
attrition so in order to do that we
learn the Chesky decomposition of the
covariance so if you've removed key it's
basically the square root for matrices
so if we learn that and then do a dot
product of that with itself then we get
definitely positive definite matrix
so there's any site complexes that have
to deal with but that's fine and so if
we sent it our widgets regression and
this is our turn to basically take our
flattened vector of covariance
parameters and turn it into matrix of
lower triangular and then multivariate
normal
takes a scale a cesky scale and a
variance so we can don't have to worry
about multiplying together and we do the
optimization over that again
and we get the same sort outputs okay so
this one's a little bit more confident I
think just because it's easy a problem
actually and so if we do the same again
we can use our MDM which in our
posterior distribution can sample from
that and that give will give us a range
of separating hyperplanes so as you can
see it's not terrible but we are because
of the nature of the approximation we've
used it's not perfect so we have mass
where there wouldn't be mass in the true
posterior because they were just sick
signal the posterior for the age of the
profession is most acute than the normal
distribution and if we wanted to be more
accurate I mean I've done this for
simplicity but it's actually very very
straightforward if we wanted to make the
posterior
approximate by a mixture of two or three
Chaldeans mixed together with the mesh
coefficients as available parameters and
that would be a lot more straightforward
and would approximate posterior
as well and the good thing is is that
that's actually incredibly easy to do
all I have to do is slightly change my
code here which implements a
multivariate normal into one that
multiplies that implements a mixture of
most variable normals and the rest will
just work the same so that's really this
method is that I can just chop and
change my proximation as I want whereas
in the previous one with the Laplace
approximation if I was looking to now do
this the same thing would be a nightmare
trying to find some approximation from
the Taylor series or something like that
okay so the next step we can take is
we've seen the past approximation using
the elbow but actually there's nothing
special there's nothing special about
logistic regression or is is a linear
function of the weights and the inputs
we could easily make that a nonlinear
function it's it's no big deal
there's nothing we've done here which
will which reviving linearity in the
elbow and so we can use the elbow as a
general loss function as the neural
network so for regression normally a
loss function or I look like inventory
would be the log of a normal
distribution or something like that this
is quite straightforward it's the mean
squared error information that we will
probably use for doing regression with
newer networks anyway and for
classification
it's the binary cross-entropy so both of
these are quite shy for the only
difference being that whereas previously
this would be X dot W now it's some
function of X in W which is a neural
network basically but it doesn't have to
be numeric to be anything to replace
these functions whatever it will exist
and we can just in just again for this
example I'm just going to use a normal
to do the approximation thing it's easy
to to work with him to find a way around
it doesn't have to be normal the same
way we could have thought makes you
normals or anything we wanted we can do
that and here as well
so the basic neural network looks almost
exactly got your gist aggression except
this is now just some arbitrary function
instead of X dot W and so the code looks
pretty much the same as well actually we
have a little bit more because we have a
lot more weights and there's a little
bit more work to do but when we sample
from the posterior we have to chop them
up into the right size and things like
that so it's all the matrix products
work pretty little bit more work but
that's not particularly complicated so
here I've just got if we've got a
forward function here I've got two
layers with a tan in the middle
hyperbolic tangent and in the middle so
this is what just as an aside this one
the reason I apply torch if you wanted
to do something like this intensive
though it probably a real headache for
you and they're all sorts of weird
tensor for a specific reshaping function
do you have to use this is just a lumpy
I just do a slice and pasta shape I
wanted to begin so that's why I use a
high-touch now and I've an intensive way
so here basically is a this is the code
that implements on your network all this
other stuff was just pre-processing and
shaping and so it's like you've already
seen before we need a combination of
inputs and weights plus do some them in
the RT and again and then a sigmoid
around the output big loss function this
is exactly the same as what we saw for
the which is depravation case so by
Nicolas entropy saying and okay
analytical care the same or exactly the
same there and we so we now we can use
this to to train for example this
classification problem was facing with
the last one again we have the same
problems with multi cardinal balls we're
learning plus definite matrices et
cetera which we use the chess key again
and if we go down so we can see exactly
the same so our place is exactly the
same but now because we using neural
network our decisions there this can be
nonlinear and we can do all the same
stuff that we wanted to do
we do it here so we can see that
actually once we want to user start
using the elbow to do things it's
actually everything just kind of falls
into place quite naturally with logistic
regression basic neural networks
whatever we'd have to care regression
classification it all just works exactly
the same it's just about identifying the
correct property terms that were using
it in the elbow so everything we've seen
so far is what would call the
approximation of a fixed model so this
is I have some model that specifying I
want to approximate it but we can't age
one further and we can say what I want
to learn the model as well so I'm not
saying there's a normal prior now with a
normal likelihood with a sigmoid around
it I'm saying
I learned that likelihood and we can do
that as well so there's like absolutely
no reason why we can't do that at all so
this is the fixed model case essentially
this is this is our model here so this
would this would have been our normal
likelihood this would've been our prior
and this is our proximation so
previously we were just learning Phi
which were our parameters of our
approximation but actually there's no
reason why we can't parameterize this
guy as well and do a maximization over
both which is basically what we can do
next
so this is the cost function or the
elbow form that we would use to learn
both it's quite simple to apply torch
all we have to do is define a few extra
parameters and optimization to take care
of the rest so
so if you want to now going to attack
what called variational auto-encoders so
these operate race in a very similar way
to auto-encoders and what could seem
with conceptually the idea is that we
use reconstructions of beta points in
order to run a model that data points so
we use a normal so first of all we
appropriate we add an additional
conditionality so we have a weight in
variable Z which before we can think
about a representation so this is like
projecting our beta down onto a small
condensed version condensed a
representation which is not much to the
vector it doesn't mean anything often
like visually it's just a lot of numbers
but it encodes information in a
particular way to our network and making
us work to do inference so we made
previously all the approximations we did
were conditioned
workwear and conditional they were just
approximations of the model but here we
convicted conditional a data points to
make it more like an autoencoder because
for a normal encoder we put a point in
we compress it and we decompress and we
compare the outputs so we can do the
same thing here so we have two
distributions these are basically the
encoder and decoder part so this is the
encoder so given a Y so I take an input
point I encode it I get a Zed and then I
put that said into my decoder so given a
Zed what's the probability of a Y and so
that's like my decoder there and then I
can do exactly the same idea and compare
the two so what I put in and what I got
back out and see how similar they are
and because I'm winning the premises
both of these that will work quite
nicely and so what we use is a normal
distribution as the output but the
parameters are given by a neural network
so each two in theory each data point
and can have its own distribution so
because the neural network will give
different output for each data point and
there those outputs are mean and
variance of the distribution so even
though they're normal and the fact that
and we use the newer network to
parameterize it give some more
flexibility and I'll final like margin
to species not normal
I think they chose it just for the
simplicity of the analytical kod again
it most of the if you work with Vaz the
the normal solution is actually that
constraining often it's more about like
the flexibility the elbow and a lot more
kind of statistical things you have to
look into because because the
instructions in your networks to give
you the parameter this gives you a lot
of flexibility that you wouldn't kind of
see if you just use a normal system okay
so yeah so basically when we're training
this whole system the weights of these
neural networks F and G as I've called
them are considered the parameters so
this can be if you have a million system
if you wanted to use in big neural
network so again just to recap the white
auto encoder basically because I take a
data point X or a switch my notation
here which should be bad at me you take
a later point it goes in it gets encoded
then come close into our P distribution
which our decoder and comes out again as
an X point and then they look they look
like you term that we get in the elbow
is I can't reconstruction to us from one
of their word this is to visualize what
happens I'll give you a minute
okay so basically we can start here we
have a data point X we encode it into
our first distribution so this is this
is in your network
it gives outputs are a mean and variance
which we then use the sample from so we
sample is it this is a encoding of the
data we we then pass that through our
decoder network which gives us a
Bernoulli parameter which we then sample
from and that gives us our data point
back again and so the Bernoulli
parameters if we have like discrete
outputs opening images or something like
that because if it's grayscale be like
basically 0 or 1 so this will be Avenue
you switch rather normal they've already
done continuously normal and then we can
do the cross entropy between these two
so this is our target and this is what
we predicted and this flows into the
elbow in the same ways before and then
we have a the analyte of care their
versions between our prior which is
normally standard and the distribution
here and so this is our last function
here that we take the gradient respect
to and minimize and then we learn the
parameters of both this network and this
network so we've got one of the simple
instructive example so often you've seen
the teacher people do run these things
on faces or things like that and while
it's good to see you like pretty
pictures it's difficult to conceptualize
about because we can't we inspect like
150 dimensional rating representation we
can't just say oh well that makes sense
to me because it's just a numbers right
and so a good example that I found was
actually using a very small encoder to
earn a distribution over essentially one
fine codings so this is simple enough
that we can actually visualize what
happens in the network so this is our
input data here so there's quite a our
points doesn't matter cause it with the
same basic big and they have ones in one
position
four dimensions so the VA implementation
potentially has so an encoder network
works basically the same as what you
would expect from a normal variation for
the normal orbit encoder story except
the outputs a mean and the variance
instead of just a single output and the
decoder is like a Bernoulli here so it
takes a Zed and returns zero ones
there's a small technical point about
because we use sampling in this process
the small technical point about sampling
with respect to the differentiable
system so basically because if I just
went to numpy and sampled the gradient I
got four like the mean of that
distribution would be wrong because the
sampling operation is also dependent on
the mean like I have a normal that's
mean a zero and my sample from it and
then I move the mean to like 150
obviously my samples move too so we have
to account for the double dependency on
the parameters of the distribution here
and so fu something called the repo
parameterization trick and if you're
interested you can go away and read
about it here but will spew about it
here and but basically we can sample
from for example as any normal
distribution by first sampling from a
standard one and doing this we
parameterize ation so the mean plus the
standard deviation of what we're looking
to sample from times on normal samples
now gives us samples which to the right
and distribution but also then we can
differentiate this term by immunes and
Sigma and everything will work properly
okay so and again our loss function is
basically the same so we've got our
binary cross entropy here and a care
divergence term and we do because we
doing mini batch basically we have to
normalize by the size of the patches
otherwise we like over sample account
divergence versus I like it
so make on water too simple and then we
have a small function which basically so
did so the encoder Network returns mu
and a Sigma and then we have a small
function that basically and uses a
reaper amortization trick to generate
samples from that so that's up here
which is the form where I wrote just up
there so basically sample from a
standard normal and in tons by the
standard deviation and add there the
mean and so when we so we can basically
just chain this now it's a clash a
forward so we have all the terms here
just reconstruction and then our lasting
our reconstruction our data and if we
run that for a while we actually get and
then we got the Z that we generate then
we actually get a nice distribution so
we can see that the rating encodings
that occur and separated so this is each
color represents like one class for
nerve edward so one position where the
one is and and so it's able to learn any
so the distribution and can separate the
different classes so we actually see
that our encoding z' mean something here
and actually had information to our
system as well and so this is the same
as if we wanted to now join him and
faces the distributions are a bit more
complicated parties begin here are
networks but it's just for the same and
the rating variables that we have would
work in a very similar way so they would
encode information about the face that
we've just encoded so obviously we can
visualize it in only very high
dimensional but you can sort kind of see
how this thing's works the good thing is
probabilistic we we get like doggins
distribution of the data kind of free so
we've learned that as part of our newly
network
which is nice okay
so does anyone have any questions just
like at this point god yep dysgraphia
yes and our latent representation is
two-dimensional so inside the encoder
yes so they're not weights they actually
like the values of the encoded
representation does that make sense
so so for example like for this class
this say this was the one where one is
at the start it's representation will be
two-dimensional and it might be like 1 1
for example and that would tell us okay
this is being coding over this class if
that makes sense
okay any other questions before we move
on no cool oh god yeah
so I can't see if you're the right
speaker yes
[Music]
yes so I guess the the point is that
you've you run a probability model as
well
so where's with a very small sorry we're
just the general it's kind of know
probably interpretation I can learn
something but then if I actually want a
joint distribution over phases for
example I have no way to if I use it so
like if I was like for example let's say
I trained it on phases and then I wanted
to take that train network and say okay
now this out-of-sample face what I want
to pass if I was to locate that this is
a face for example I composite in a
network and because I have a probably a
probability system they probably tell me
ok yes a really high probability that
this is a face or where you go probably
to this is a face so you kind of get
like the whole system for free words
with an autoencoder
you just get the encoding it doesn't
really give you anything else problem
that if that makes sense
ok cool all right we'll get ok ok so the
next thing we can in fact it's gonna
seem like a a bit of a step away from
what we've done before but is relevant I
promise and so generally I think we
probably seem discriminators before so
essentially just classifiers we just
classify is it across X or Y it doesn't
try to learn the generative distribution
so we do these actually have a
probability interpretation it's kind of
you ever studied like Beijing decision
theory you've probably done this and
then I completely forgotten about it and
this is gonna kind of be like a
reawakening for you I guess so if we so
this is what the output of a normal
discriminator would be so their
probability that 82 points across one
for example and so he's basically them
to do the inversion of this basically
and if we make the very sorry mild
assumption that our base point is our
beta is evenly distributed between two
classes we can essentially cancel the
prize
and so we get this turn down here and
then if we do a little bit rearranging
we can show that we can see that
actually this is I can write this as a
Sigma basically with some odd ratio in
the same light so lit and this is
actually the form we see in a neural
network so if we were changing your
network this is this here would be the
function right so we'd have a sigmoid
around some function of the inputs be
complicated one bit it'd be some
function and so we can kind of see that
actually there's like an equivalence
here in that I can if I train it
discrimination which claims not to learn
distributions actually it kind of does
because as long as this term here is
good then it's Gajic holds obviously if
we don't train the discriminate it just
work and we can't apply this logic but
assuming we learn a good discriminator
we can make this equivalence and say
actually there's a reservation here
between these terms so I actually kind
of get by training the discriminator on
base points so say I'm training to
discriminate between handbags and shoes
images of homos and shoes and what on
the surface that seems like it's not
pretty probably stick but actually it
kind of is because we can see under the
hood we were actually learning ratios of
probability distributions here and these
are distributions which we can't
articulate I've no idea what the
distribution of data points that are or
images our shoes looks like and that's
obviously can be very complicated
but we obviously from the squivers we
can see that we learn it and just to
demonstrate this I've got a small
demonstration
so again we're going to use the standard
famous normal distribution just because
it's a lot easier and it's implemented
in apply torch for us and so here I've
got a really box and classification
discriminator just a ton of layers some
values in between and a cross entropy
and a sigmoid on the output this is like
nothing fancy at all just a
discriminator and so we're going to do
it again some very dimensional simple
data points just because it again is
easy to view at visualize and so we've
got two classes are as I call them got a
normal distribution here in the center
in red and on top of this we've got a
uniform distribution so the task we're
gonna initially solve is can we
discriminate between the right data
points and the blue of its points which
is what we train our discriminate to do
so we use Adam and just I've got a
little clapping function here so if you
can see the progress is it evolves and
this is the training so inputs go in
discriminator gradient optimization step
quite every so often and so we can see
that we start off with a really bad
decision surface obviously it's pretty
much random and I hope you can see that
yeah the data points are kind of like
superimposed with a right alpha just so
we can see what happens underneath and
we see quite quickly it starts to earn a
good decision surface cool so this is
make sense I'd say it will trained a
good classifier here it's pretty
confident that all these data points
here are from from class 1 and that
everything else is not from across one
so from Gaza zero they've gonna quit but
if we use that logic that we found it
before so if I just do that
so we can see that there's the
equivalents here between this term here
and this term here so if we if we do a
little bit of algebra we can multiply
that out and it becomes that this ratio
here is equal to the ratio of p y equals
want to give an X divided by P y equals
0 given X so if I all I've done here is
essentially implement that so I've been
lazy this here is the probability of a
uniform distribution over knoweven by 11
grid and so we've taken so this is
essentially that for me I rearranged to
make to change the subject and if we
plot that then we see okay we get a
distribution which is kind of circular
like a normal and if we compare this now
versus the true we can see that actually
our proximation is not half bad as in
the peak of our distributions about
right and the shape looks fairly good
zoom out a little bit so even though
this method has said it's discriminative
it doesn't learn a generative model
actually we can see it does because it's
relatively straightforward to back out
an approximate probability distribution
from the discriminator and so this is
kind of actually important because
methods like ganz for example use
discriminators as their core and they're
like trying to to use that as an
adversarial mechanism to train their
network but actually we can see that
discriminators are learning probability
distributions that's really important
link to make because it allows us to
take this thing that seems empirical and
to push it into a probability space
because we can we can now say also
actually is learning a ratio those
publications will proceed from there and
there's a I haven't done it here there's
a good paper called an adversarial
variational base which basically takes a
very small encoder and plugs in a
discriminator using exactly the same
logic it's quite straightforward I
recommend that you look into it and so
we can see that and there's also a
series of talks by a guy called
oh sorry bye Uncle Frank ooh he has a
big series on this kind of using
discriminators for implicit eternity
models as well but just time I've had to
skip that out okay okay so that's kind
of a roundup they vary from foreign
section however you can see where this
is all going now we've covered
discriminators we've gone to ganz now
and we're gonna put it all together
does anyone have any questions for you
no cool and yeah so just take a step
back and say what cans are they using an
adversarial approach so I think when I
first introduced they kind of made the
analogy of you've got a counterfeiter
and the police and the fact that they're
police looking for the counterfeit it
makes the counterfeit and make better
money because if you makes bad money to
police find it very quickly and that by
iterating at that process for a long
time you kind of get like a Nash
equilibrium of where the counterfeit is
so good the priest can't tell and
because this and because they're kind of
even level the priests and they long
able to learn from the counterfeiter how
to decant if that makes sense
so again this is what I was talking
about about how we can be curiously
motivated for things and seeing things
through like a variational lens for one
of their word house just actually
introspect these methods a bit more
because that story's really cool but it
doesn't really like apply method their
problem does it so it's kind of a useful
tool for nuts and so in to be for more
the loss function for a gun is basically
this is the loss function is the cross
entropy basically minimize G and
maximize DC you want the generator
essentially to make the discriminator
think or it's fake samples are real and
you want discriminator to be able to
tell between fake and real samples so
the idea of this is basically I'd have a
weight of data so faces there's a common
one I put faces in and make my generator
generate the fake faces and I put them
through discriminations
screaming would have to tell is this a
real face always this one the generator
made and so by iterating through that
cycle cycle you hope that the generator
gets so good it can fall the
discriminator now and then you kind of
learn a really cool distribution over
I've had to generate faces okay so we've
got again a really simple example again
low dimensional because we can think
about the way that I mentioned Z Z and
so this is why I was talking about here
in my previous section so we have two
jr. networks here a generator and a
discriminator so this guy essentially
returns data in the same format as our
input samples and the discriminator is
standard community that we saw before
returns probably th class 1 or class 0
and so if we imagine we've got this kind
of weird correlated lot of points so
this is what we're trying to learn so we
want to we're saying I want to learn a
generator that can sample from this
distribution for me and so what all we
have to do is train our generator to
schematic pair and to do that so because
the original formulation relies on
optimal discriminators so the basically
discriminator is the the more signal the
generator has to learn how to make
itself better because it can learn what
the discrimination was written for in
its samples to basically discriminate
between the two so having a strong
strong discriminator generally a
training so as you can see so what I've
done here is for every step we take
which n the generator sorry this
committee at five times and we take
generator once so that the discriminator
kind of gets a bit more time to get good
at its task and then that provides a lot
more signal to the generator kind of can
help stability but this is a whole
massive topic that we have time to go
into and so yes quite straightforward
so essentially and the generator take
two random noise as a way to make sure
that it doesn't just collapse because if
I put a tennis input in your network I
get a misty output and so of course you
could just like fool that whole system
then by saying well just remember this
one point and that's the fake point
right so if you put in normal noise it
forces the discriminator generator to be
able to generate a range of samples
which is all we want so we're not
looking to generate generate any one
single sample from this dais upon one
two sample from it so this is said here
is our random noise basically so we
generate fake theta and then we run that
through our discriminator and we take
the loss with respect to that basically
by a across entropy and the same for the
for the discriminator up here so this is
generators greater they both use the
same loss function to the greatest of
any different parameters that's anything
and when we do that we see okay cool
right it's all trained and now we
generate some more random noise we pass
that through our generator now so this
is in theory free trained so by doing
this we're sampling from what the
generators earned and we can see
actually the red points of the generator
and the blue points are the inputs so
actually this is pretty good we were
lucky to go in to sample from there and
we can see like if we just do you'll see
boron plot we can see that these
actually look reasonably good so this is
the is the real data here so I'm putting
my screen you can see me do that this is
real data here this is generate a and
I'd say actually later look
like they're from very similar
distributions their margins are very
similar this one looks more like the
original than the other one did so I
would say that's probably success and so
again this process is simple to show
with data points like this but it's no
different if we want to know images
faces user faces are just vectors of
data right so it's the same principle
just a bit of higher dimensional bit
more finicky to Train big in your
networks but the idea is exactly the
same okay but so I've talked a little
bit around a very common issue that we
see with Ganz if you read about Ganz for
even like five minutes someone will talk
about mode dropping in the basic
overview basically imagine I'm training
to generate items of clothing motor
rocking would be when the system just
learns the generate shoes for me so it
may generate amazing shoes but it
doesn't really an elephant wasn't reward
looking for I wanted to generate the
whole the whole range of crows I wanted
shirts t-shirts etc and in theory this
shouldn't happen so if we use the
previous kind of logic that we applied
and we see and we substitute the
discriminator for the probabilistic
alternative that we will show those
equivalent Early's and base theorem we
can see that we go sir which is a cow
divergence basically kind of dissipation
rate detergent sound divergence as well
and and this is symmetric so it doesn't
really matter if I am permitted P D and
P G so P DS with about discriminator and
VG's are generated so P D I'd miss cable
this this should be real so this is our
real data and this is I generated data
so say people eat these it's symmetric
so it shouldn't we shouldn't have like
you know how we saw at the beginning we
wear some formation of our loss function
was most seeking and some formulation
was mode covering if it's symmetric
economy exhibit that because
you can swap you could swap a problem
and it should work the same so in theory
this shouldn't happen and we shouldn't
have moe dropping in ganz but we do we
see empirically so in the short answer
is that this logic only holds for bit
beers you substituting and it holds for
an optimal discriminator so that's
probably not true right especially if
we're like training on images of faces
or something very complicated I mean
it's a [ __ ] task in itself to do
discriminative classification 100% on a
real general data set so the idea that
we can do it by training like one step
at a time and that's always going to be
optimal it's probably strong so that we
can kind of see where that comes from
there so this is basically what I just
said in practice these assumptions that
began formation we're eyes on no even
close to being true
sometimes it's criminally actually
terrible for half violations and so is
we have to a bit different ways so it's
possible to derive a result that doesn't
rely on to merit on the optimal
discriminator this is a paper I said
going to I see a bar tomorrow being
presented tomorrow so we're beating them
by one day so I recommend to check that
out as well
I've got your demonstration here
okay so this is known to be a problem
for a little while so there's a very
good and easy to comprehend basically
demonstration of this which we're going
to see the end of the practical session
of it and this is from paper called
unrolled gender Sarah networks they
proposed a solution with a nice good
solution as an exercise to the reader
but basically the the technique they
used to demonstrate no dropping it so I
produce that here so this is the exactly
same codes before God generator
discriminator
and now instead of a single class of 80
points one sample form we're going to
take a diamond so this is why this looks
a bit nasty I mean this is probably
which we nothing compared to that the
manifold of that human face is rest on
all horses or things like that like so
these are obviously incredibly
complicated distribution so it should
have no problem with earning this right
and so this is just like essentially six
or seven or eight normal distributions
put in a diamond shape and if we trained
on that we've got again your output to
see how it evolves so as we can see
starts off in the middle because this is
basically a random noise here so it's
just generating random noise as it
before we train it as we train it quite
quickly we see it just zooms in on one
of your coasters and stays there and
never remakes any attempts to do any
better I mean I'm not sure what this is
maybe it says some attempt to like leap
across to to another one but as soon
sites that are known I'm gonna not
bother with that and we basically end up
it's focusing on one crafter so the
final form we can see we do some
generate some samples again and pop
those we see basically all we can do is
sample from this one so we probably go
this one quite well but if we care about
learning a model which learns all of
these I mean it's probably not quite as
success as we can see from
the rocks are quite different here right
so just a small roundup of putting all
together if you want to I mean using the
kind of like you've got ideas that I
didn't used here so like generators is
discriminators there's probabilistic
methods and things like that you can
actually reformulate the Gann objective
in a more probabilistic sense and you
can get a kind of unification between
Gans of EA's it's not particularly hard
the paper they could have maybe done a
little bit nicer job making it
accessible the notation is quite quite
dense and you have lots of
discriminators versus other types of
discriminators but i recommend that you
go through it takes a bit of time it's
genuinely worth it and I just going to
do real not made much maths and point to
them any result that we can see so this
is the formation they use they a
discriminator is a probably a probably
distribution so it's probably that wise
some of course given our data so they
rephrase it like that and they dump all
of our they threw all the data together
so the data that are generated generates
and the real data put into one data set
and basically use this notation so
conditional on Y which is the variable
we were fake and if you do that I sense
you have skipped out a lot of steps but
you can kind of show that this is the
expectation over some Joint Distribution
of our data and our ables over the
discriminator so this is the
discriminate sit here again we run
derive here but actually if you don't
take a derivative of this with respect
to the parameters about generator you
actually get something that's basically
this term yes like I'm a half constant
basically which is a cow divergence
between our generator the description of
our generator and so this term is like
our inverter discriminator so you can
see this is being
that term a big like we did in the
discriminator netbook and this is the
distribution in provided by a
discriminator so this is kind of our end
approximation and so while we and so in
va es we had to explicitly in Gans here
we've managed to back it out and it is
typically using base theorem basically
and the Jensens Chand divergence is a
symmetric distribution so we can kind of
ignore this term because it doesn't it
doesn't we're looking at things that
mode dropping it doesn't have any impact
it's just kind of a constants k in
factored form of a better word do they
it doesn't favor one type of mode
dropping versus no covering et cetera so
if we just see they're like just could
say if we ignore the the JFD term we
have that for ganz we're kind of pseudo
optimizing and a cow divergence of P
even Q now because we learn both an
approximation which is Q and a generator
which is P we kind of have like we have
both situations that we saw before as in
one of them is gonna be mode covering
and one of them is going to be mote
seeking because depending which one
we're taking a gradient with respect to
one's gonna be and on the denominator I
was going to quit on the numerator so if
we look at the generator P which is they
learned model of a better word we can
see that Ganz optimized PDM Q so this
causes mode seeking behavior so like we
saw in the first notebook where we had a
normally should be focusing on one of
the two this is this is exactly the same
so our generator is kind of encouraged
to focus on a sit on a single mode of
the data point that is where mode
dropping comes from because essentially
our generator is mode seeking so doesn't
matter how good our proximation is if
the thing we're próxima ting is mo
taking our proximation is going to be
mighty king
whereas VA es if we remember from the
elbow is the other way around because we
wanted to minimize the caldera edges
between our proximation and the true
posterior so this is why we have so we
have mass covering behavior there so our
real distribution or
and event true distribution has a moat
covering behavior so this is kind of
explained some of the things we see with
the age because when we see the age in
hitch are they never recompete with gans
active you see human faces from the two
gang always from pal perform and so this
is because just like we had in the first
notebook where we had that normally
solution that cover it covered all the
mass they kind of think we get right the
relative proportions of how high these
distributions went so we see this going
on again with vs in that we kind of get
a better space to sample from but we
kind of don't really ever focus in on
one part of that space world so our
samples can it be a bit washed out and
comparison something like ants but we
get the other allergic so we don't get
so much mo Tiki okay that was kind of
pretty much my Whistlestop tour
I guess just in summary I I hope you
forward most of that and we can kind of
see how it's like there's a nice clean
path to go right the way from like
basing linear aggression of conjugal
models we can take that and by making
further and further reacts Asians and
approximating things we can go all the
way through to non conjugate models
version encoders and in Ganz end up kind
of like really the state of the art of
what's going on in defensive models of
the moment and also there's always been
like a bit of rivalry
I should our V azor Ganz the one which
one's the best D genitive model that we
should be using actually we're kind of
signed to see coming out in the
literature now they're kind of not
necessarily particularly different they
started off from very different
motivations but actually we start to
unify them quite well and it's starting
to become ever more merged and we see
lots of papers coming out now for like
that have again
be a hybrid and use methods from both
and actually just as a point for
people's understanding learning if you
want to learn about this stuff there's
tons of people who put blog posts up
about like I generate this picture of a
horse it's really great to see you I
fake the pictures of horses but if you
actually want to like you just want to
learn about how this stuff works you
need stuff that you can sort of Zone in
on and so there's no reason why these
don't work for a reason poor
toy problems and actually that's where
you should start not just straight to
the big time that's it any final
questions from anyone
yes yeah okay well I mean so it depends
what we talk about so if we're talking
about like Bayesian methods so for
getting good tailored predictive
propositions but in general that they
for me they have application where you
can't you have kind of an asymmetry so
if I'm doing about NLP it kind of
doesn't really matter there's no obvious
worst case if I miss classify a text
point right but I gave the example if I
might landing an airplane it's probably
better that I only ever try to land
airplanes on things I'm a hundred
percent confident our airfields so you
kind of have the asymmetry there like
there's very good of cost for not for
basically not taking an action so if I'm
not confident I'm not doing it cost me
basically nothing but actually doing the
wrong thing is really important so in
general probably see methods like that
any in any sort of frame of work so like
for example finance it'd be another one
right you like it's better to not not
trade there needs to trade wrongly and
so if you're in any kind of environment
where I have this biggest asymmetry it's
probably useful to have kind of these
really these good predictive
distributions for VA egg and
specifically I think the industrial uses
are kind of only just coming out I mean
there's obvious benefits to having
well-tailored generators I can sample
from so one I think actually holds some
sort of a promises things like weather
for example like the sort of systems
that go in mythological systems are very
very complicated and actually if we
could train models rather than having to
work with a complete distribution that
we specify if we were just trained to
essentially simulate from this then that
would probably be more useful because
actually what we do anyway we simulate
right we don't we never like solve the
weather function and so I think
industrial applications are kind of at
the moment I think people that Twitter
as well use
Vaz and similar kind of methods to do
things like image compression I think
it's very much on these stage now but
this stuff is like definitely on the app
and everything starts out off with like
simple toy examples and very quickly we
kind of and pop so for me it's like a
continuation of the stuff that we've
been doing before but a lot more
complicated okay yes yep yes and so
tense fur has Edwards which is a
probably programming age and they've
also got integrated something to the
Cork's name probably enshrine for a bit
and for me like I think it depends what
you're doing because you can you can
kind of see tensorflow is like a
compiled language so you kind of specify
everything up front and as soon as
anything doesn't work it just like blows
up on you basically
so maybe if you're doing something like
like your Twitter and you're running
something in production you may be
warned that certainty of a kind of
compiled framework so I know that like
we just have a nice explosion when
things don't work out whereas Python
keys I see is much more like an R&D
framework so if you were him to mess
around you have to worry about oh if I
just wiped my computational graph and
like what's happened if I just like
because I've run two cells in a notebook
in the wrong war that I've attached it
to some weird point on the graph and now
I think it's exploded didn't I don't
know why so like for me my kind of
process is generally like I'll mess
around in numpy for a bit and then I'll
go cool this is like something I want to
take forward and you'll kind of go all
right well PI torch is basically import
PI torch works out numpy 98% at the time
so I don't think is it is any particular
pros or cons I think it just depends on
what you're doing
if he's now indeed alpha-i favorite play
torch but I know people who use tents
paper on D it's pretty much personal
preference I think okay any any other
final questions okay okay just to finish
off I won't spend any time on it there's
a few references further reading good
well posts onto these topics it's
virtually a spider's web if you try and
start digging into any one of these you
will say goodbye to a weekend probably
but these are really really good places
to get some introductions and
jumping-off points from for more stuff
basically and the paper that I reference
right at the end was this one here on
unifying teacher into models I see that
2018 and in my blog which has a few of
this stuff here that I do when I'm bored
so okay thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]